happy Monday you little nickel-plated
nutsacks it's about that time again
you've been eating cat [ __ ] all weekend
huh
you've been cracking open across a can
of cat [ __ ] well show it [ __ ] boy
but to Serpa you up this mad mountain of
mundaneness
you guys ready do you think I've Michael
landed on my shirt well Oh welcome to
this past weekend this past weekend hear
that at the Cambridge slang that's what
that's all that sound is called listen
to it
[Music]
it kind of sounds like the kind of sound
that like when everything is going like
in the movie like when the couple is you
know the route and finally everything's
going great it's like the third date and
it's just a montage and they're dancing
and like spending each other around in
the rain and like listen listen yeah you
see yeah we we got the third date in the
books and now we're just we're bowling
and kissing and you know trying on our
bowling shoes and laughing and like
punching each other softly soft punches
and doing stuff like that you know or if
you take maybe two squirrels I don't if
you ever spend any time around
squirrels they're basically they're
basically a very short ferret but with a
tail on it kind of and they are they're
exciting animals they're animals that
are I don't want to say they're
beautiful animals but I think they're
I'll sit and talk with you about them
all day they are very enticing enticing
species the squirrel but yeah this
seemed like a couple of them were just
kind of in the trees going nuts listen
[Music]
just kind of running around and like
grabbing like acorns and peeking out
from behind the other tree and like
scurrying up the branches there you go
it's a little bit of Cambridge twang
that's the song right there and we are
here with you and this is Monday June
5th and welcome to this past weekend
appreciate you guys joining us today but
you already knew that I have a feeling
that you already knew that because I let
you know all the time I'm coming to you
live for me for now on this saw Mondays
of June and that means summertime is
coming right around the corner the
Solstice is coming up I believe that's
June 21st or 22nd and that should be the
that the longest day of the year yeah so
if you got um you know if you got a
friend that talks a lot I wouldn't hang
out with them on that day because you're
liable to be out there out and about
having to listen to them a little bit
longer than usual so I you know spend
that day with people who don't talk too
much and who are you know just use if
you like to have fun with you don't have
to really listen very much as much or
more than you should
I'm in Pittsburgh coming to you live
from a Courtyard Marriott very basic you
could call it a hotel like it's kind of
a motel to me there's a kind of a very
girthy sort of Indian or Middle Eastern
man downstairs who I'm going to go out
on a limb and say this fella wants to do
sex with me
he keeps baiting me downstairs saying
that the printer is fixed the printer is
fixed and it's broken and then he's like
oh whatever he's British as well and
he's like oh whatever am I to do I'm
just Jeepers Creepers and the night
shift the people that worked a night
shift at hotels man I mean every their
coolest [ __ ] or they are [ __ ] up
because I have seen both types man I
have seen
both types dude a lot of one guy took me
back in this baggage room where they
kept a bunch of baggage one time and he
had a German Shepherd back there giving
baby's birth whelping they call it when
they given birth like that this German
Shepherd back there giving birth to baby
animals little baby German Shepherd you
know that so I just don't know what the
[ __ ] is going on honestly at some of
these places and I'm sorry to get fired
up out of the gate and use this language
but you know I've been out here in
Pittsburgh for four nights good city but
I'm on the outskirts you know I'm out
here at one of these malls and this is
the kind of times when in a comedian's
life dude it's not great it's not great
we're going to go home I'm tired but
with that said I had some joy this
weekend you can look on the youtubes if
you're on the youtubes um I got a
gentleman that makes some of my shirts
this gentleman Kevin best and he showed
up and made me some beautiful shirts man
so that really really cool and this one
is a Michael Landon who you know I've
always thought of as like a television
prophet actor you know who really kind
of led or tried to help lead everybody
in the positive direction before he died
a cancer and cancer got him dude I'm
starting to wonder like what diseases
are we gonna have from our this
technology we have right now you know
like we don't know anybody who has hit
65 years old and who's been on a phone
on a cell phone for 40 years we don't
know the effects we don't know the
effects of a lot of the medicines that
were on right now I mean I'm just what
if at you know 70 years old somebody
who's been using the cell phone for 30
years what if their [ __ ] eyeballs
fall out of their head huh what if
that's one of the afflictions you know
and you got a bunch of people running
around with no eyes or walking slowly
and still and being angry at Verizon but
still addicted to their phones how crazy
is that going to look when you
have a guy with no eyes no eyes in his
head and you're like what happened to
you
and he says sorry I can't talk right now
I'm on the phone even though it's the
phone that did it to them that's where
we're headed guys we got some great
callers that called in about one I'm
going to leave us with today a caller
called a few weeks ago about the future
and I'm going to leave us with that one
at the end of the lineup today so you
can see what you think he had a really
great a good point a good topic that I
want to lead us into and we can talk
about that but first I want to tell you
about the hearing here in Pittsburgh man
I'm here it's been a good time
Pittsburgh Improv had some nice people
came out the neon nightingale he came
out he came out you guys remember him
from some of the previous episodes and
that was pretty sweet having him out and
about I've got to meet him and his
lovely lady and they gots a child that
they left somewhere at home under the
care of someone else
so that's proper way to do it but I've
been in Pittsburgh all weekend
it rained today that's about the most
exciting thing kind of happened to me
spend time with my buddies family what
else I had a lot of nice lovely fans
that came out man lovely fans and
friends I'm going to tell you where I'm
going up soon and then we'll get into
the news and then we're going to hit
into some calls and emails from people
from from listeners that we're going to
offer some basic life suggestions people
that hit the hotline I'm going to give
you that hotline number right now nine
eight five six six four nine five zero
three and the cities I'm hitting soon
Nashville Las Vegas Orlando Colusa
casino in North north of Sacramento New
York City Stark County Illinois
so those places are going to be coming
up as well as addison texas that's in
dallas or outside of dallas on that
second week of august but all those
other all those other cities are before
the end of July you can find them at
diovan dot-com slash tore tou R as well
I got the new album that's out now must
get fire the early years of satire
and 30 pound bag of hamster bones both
those are available right now
check the tracks and make sure you don't
already own the album though I'm happy
to be here with you guys man I'm happy
to be here with you guys
Bill Cosby case is starting today you
may know that you may not from me from
to me
I think the Bill Cosby is guilty do I
think he's guilty of you know copulating
with all however many of those women are
I don't I don't think he's guilty of all
of them just based on my experience in
LA I see easily see how when one woman
see that something's going on
others will jump on and it's not just a
woman people you know they're they're
doling out money over here let me jump
in there's a lot of hot ass out there in
Los Angeles a lot of gold-digging
trifling women out there just trying to
make a buck you know I mean I'm not even
talking feminists these aren't feminists
these are Rottweilers okay these are
them you know them cooter Rottweilers
and they're just barking around with
that crotch and trying to get that money
stack that paper you know but I think
that I think I don't think that Bill
Cosby will can be convicted I think you
might be convicted of some civil charges
but I think you'll be the OJ Simpson of
vagina and and that's my theory there
you go there you have it I I believe
that I think you'll get off and I think
you'll be the OJ Simpson of quaza
onwards more news Kathy Griffin you
everybody knows this the bloody heads
held up I'm going to say this I and some
people think like I even talking about
it you're giving you know you're
creating publicity for her I'm not
creating publicity for Kathy Griffin
she's the only person comedian that I
that I've ever gone to their show a full
hour and I didn't laugh that's a true
story
this is about seven years ago I win or
eight could have been eight years ago I
didn't laugh at all she's not for me
her type of comedy
I get it but I thought that this was
just hack you know I thought it was just
you know you're holding up a bloody head
of the president get a life you know
you've made your money in this country
and show some gratitude you don't have
to show it to Donald Trump but you show
it to the fact that that's the president
for right now you know that to the
president is you know and I don't care
who it is I think that as an American
you have some responsibility to at least
just go along with it and I just think
she could have come up with something
much better or funnier to me she's not
funny and to me I just thought that that
was unamerican that kind of the feeling
that it left me with you know and I'm
kind of just sick of all the Trump I'm
just I think the Trump jokes are just
hack it's like we get it like you don't
like him okay great you know I mean I
voted for Obama twice I wasn't a huge
Obama fan you know but I was inspired by
what he was talking about I think Obama
did some good I think he was a great
example I also think Obama was kind of a
[ __ ] when it came to a lot of stuff to
be honest sorry to use that language I
felt like he didn't really have any
balls you know I don't think he did a
lot to inspire black America for me
that's just my perspective you're like
we'll see you're not black you're right
I'm not but I can still have a point of
view a lot of my black friends have felt
the same way I think he's a great
speaker I think he's a great order I
think he sounds it amazing no doubt he
looked good in pictures beautiful family
beautiful daughters
probably a great hoopster but to me he
was all talk he was more of a celebrity
than he was a man I would look at him as
more of a celebrity than I would as a
man so I mother Kathy Griffin thing I
just didn't laugh you know it wasn't
funny to me I think she's more of a
loudmouth
uh-uh and maybe she was a comedian at a
time but I've never seen her in a comedy
club never seen her in any comedy club
anywhere except for the one time I went
saw a theater and and part of that I'm
just sick of the unamerican attitude
like like people saying that oh this
country doesn't represent me and stuff
like that like maybe I'm old-fashioned
or something
no but like I feel hold on the
air-conditioners came on I gotta shut it
off alright I'm back but I feel like if
you live in the country you cash your
checks here didn't have some gratitude
you know have some freaking gratitude
you know if you don't like what's going
on then find some ways to change it be
part of the solution you know shut the
[ __ ] up and contribute alright you don't
have to make it bet you're not going to
make it better by acting like you're not
part of this country if you don't to be
part of the country then go go out for a
few years and come back nobody's doing
that you see what I'm saying
everybody's anti America but they're not
leaving here so it just kind of makes me
upset you know and you can say well Theo
you're naive you know you still believe
in some type of an American ideal or
American Dream you know I don't know how
clearly I feel on some of that but I do
feel like we're fortunate enough to live
here we're blessed to live in this
country we should act like it we should
act like it you know and if something we
don't like find a more constructive way
than just by sheer hatred you know I
just don't get it
Bill Maher dropped the n-word that's a
little more news there um I thought with
Bill Maher in comparison to Kathy
Griffin at least Bill Maher that's him
you know who he is you know I I'm not
going to sit here and pretend like I
don't live in a world where I know
personally hundreds of people who you
would think never use the n-word who I
hear use it I'm not going to sit in a
world and pretend that that that's the
case people use it a lot you know they
don't use er but I hear ni GGA all the
time and I don't condone it I don't
think it's I don't think it helps I do
think it's a derogatory word right but I
believe that it's going to take time for
us to get it out of the vocabulary of
humanity and I think that today more
kids learn it today from music that
they do from racist channels or
influences how do we defeat it for me I
think that you take it out of music and
you let time pass you just need time but
also that's just my thoughts on it some
people are like you're white you don't
get to comment on it and that's
understandable if somebody takes that
stance I might have maybe almost agree
with them you know you know that's a
weird ground but I think with Bill Maher
Bill Maher you just know who he is that
- he is he's the kind of guy who drops a
wild joke like that who is not afraid to
use a word like that I'm not surprised I
mean Bill Maher's really spicy he's
derogatory he's you know he's always
misogynistic he's I think in a way he's
kind of like a trump in a way you know
and I'm not saying that that's that he's
a horrible person I don't know the man
but I'm saying that I feel like at least
you you get who he is you're not shocked
I don't know who was super shocked by
that like I know people on Twitter get
angry but Twitter angriness to me not
even real - angry if you're too angry
that's not real that's fake if you just
sit there and tweet something and then
do nothing about it or have no it's just
to me it seems a really really fake but
as but as compared to Kathy Griffin
Kathy Griffin you have no idea who she
is you just think oh she's just this
Muppet trying to make some weird splash
and it didn't go well and she's blaming
white people just just give it up you
seem to have led a pretty privileged
life and she just seems to have no
gratitude for that and that just pissed
me off and you don't have any idea Kathy
Griffin is she's just snarky kind of
early Perez Hilton sort of she was like
kind of like a human TMZ that just told
he's weird behind-the-scenes stories
about celebrities that I never thought
were super funny and then she just like
Cal toed to the gay community for her
fanship but gamar I mean that's who he
is
you know at least you're like oh that's
exactly who he is Kathy Griffin you're
like what the [ __ ] is this ladies out of
her mind
anyway so this is all my thoughts on the
news
what else is going on I mean they have
the tragedy over there in England I
don't know what to think about that kind
of stuff you know I'm it's crazy to
think you on our military get involved
in things too that's just kind of scary
you know but uh but yeah I mean I just
you know my thoughts and prayers are
really with those with those people who
you know Jim them with their children
and having to deal with that and I like
thoughts and prayers some people don't
like them I mean to me all a thought or
a prayer is it's a it's hope it's a
moment of meditation it's a moment of
you trying to express good energy
towards people that need it and to me
there's a ton of value in that people
are always like thoughts and prayers
don't solve anything I disagree
you know surely they're not going to
make you a sandwich you know if you
thinking and praying for Bologna and
cheese to meat in your kitchen you're
dead wrong but if you're thinking and
praying that that that the hearts of
someone who is hurting could find more
comfort I think that things like that
can really occur so I believe in some of
those things we get the hotline man I'm
going to get right into it because it's
it's late bro it's late for me and and I
don't want to live like this
I don't want to live up this late I just
want to get some I want to get some rest
to be honest I got to flight in four
hours and 50 minutes I'm flying out of
Pittsburgh so let's get it in I'll say
this on the hotline that number again
nine eight five six six four nine five
zero three the first one we got our
message that came in this is a text and
then we'll get to some calls
Theo Austin here texting in from the
University of Central Missouri your last
podcast you said you attended six
different universities next year I
graduate and start the process of paying
off my student loans and was wondering
how you handled all your debt if you had
any and any advice as a jump into the
real world with loads of debt thank you
you're the mother effing
and here's what I say about student
loans young buck austin named after a
city i've always wanted to have a
daughter named chicago i thought that'd
be a neat name or or maybe a son named
st. petersburg but here's what i want to
say about student loans dude don't worry
about that that's my thought on it i
mean because you can get your student
loans down to where you're paying like a
little bit of money basically over the
rest of your life
you know i've been out of school for
fifteen years a refinance them here and
there i basically have paid
there were times where I didn't pay
anything where they gave me some you
know a lien a period of grace period but
otherwise I probably paid 100 bucks a
month for about 15 years but you know
what don't worry about that [ __ ] dude
because if you worry about small stuff
then you live small that's one thing
I'll notice if I can go back in time if
you worry small you live small you're
worried about all that small [ __ ] dude
you're gonna you never you're worried
about that small [ __ ] you will never
make a stink man that's what I'm gonna
tell you you got a worry big dude you
know I mean you think about this you
might get in with a company in five
years and not have to even pay your
student loans some companies when you
come to work for them part of the the
contract is they pay off your student
loans I mean there are real
possibilities like that in your future
so for you sitting there worrying about
that hundred dollars a month the I
promise you you will be okay that
doesn't mean go out and drink every
night not take care of yourself and not
have a job but find employment and worry
big you know I'd worry about how am I
going to own a rental property in five
years that's a bigger goal man I take on
a bigger goal like that set a goal like
that instead of these you're worrying
down here you're living down here if
you're worrying up here you're living up
here so I get up there man that's what
I'd say you know don't look at it as oh
I owe $150,000 that's huge that's crazy
look at it as
oh I owe a hundred bucks a month because
I borrowed an education and I got to pay
it back don't waste the education man
just get out there stay busy State stay
busy a man should always be working I
used to live with a friend of mine and
his uh and his dad told me that it's one
thing he told me he said a man should
always be working I mean every day but I
mean you should have a job good luck out
there Austin alright let's get to a call
here let's see what we got a CEO this is
Alex in Atlanta just giving you a call
of the podcast I wanted to be advice on
a roommate situation I have this is Alex
and Atlanta calling about a roommate
situation he has I live with a good
friend recently moved in with him but
I'm having trouble sort of adapting back
to having a roommate is sort of a kid
who comes from money and seems to never
leave had any responsibility in his life
I'm quite the opposite you know okay so
he moved back in with a roommate it
sounds like he didn't have a roommate
and now he's moved back in with the
roommate he's having trouble adjusting
to that and and the roommate is maybe
more of a silver spoon type of boy like
he's had types of things given to him
onward you know I've got a full-time job
has since I graduated I've been in high
school and worked for all my bills and I
just kind of kind of been a struggle for
me sort of not kind of being an [ __ ]
to him coming off as a prick of a
roommate but it's just one of those
things where you know sleeps all day you
know the few responsibilities
responsibilities I give them to benefit
the two of us oh wow so he's saying that
you know he it's hard for him not to be
a prick to his roommate but then you say
Alex because Alex you said the few
responsibilities you give him so it
seems like you're your take on this you
know ya seem like you're having trouble
adapting to being in a roommate
situation too because you're given this
dude
you know if you're like given demands
out of him it sounds like you're not
getting some of those things you're not
going to get you know if you're
expecting him to do all these things and
expecting him to live a certain way he's
an adult too you know he's going to he
might be set in his ways it sounds like
you're more angry that you have to now
live with someone to me here let's hear
at the end of this request move us as
roommates you just you know takes
forever to do anything and just never
really gets anything done but just you
know wanted to get your advice on that I
appreciate it love your podcast all
right man thank you so much for calling
in about it so you got the new roommate
here's what I think man I think it you I
don't if you ever going to be happy with
him if he started out in this vibe where
he doesn't contribute enough for the few
responsibilities you give him he doesn't
get done you gonna have to find a way to
get out of that wholesome out of that
whole mindset otherwise you're going to
drive yourself miserable because it
sounds like he's livin it up you know
you know we've got it comfortable in a
tough situation he's got a roommate he's
resting his parents are taking care of
things that's going to be his life for
now you know and if you guys are arguing
that it's only going to make things even
worse so you you don't want to get into
an argumentative state man you know
maybe if he doesn't want to contribute
and there are things he has to do maybe
see if he'd be willing to put in with to
a cleaner like a house cleaner that
comes once a week you know that way he
can get whatever his responsibilities
are done make his responsibilities some
of the cleaning and then he can pay to
have them done so that way it takes off
of his chest but you can't feel bad if
he's not physically doing those things
you can expect him out of him but at a
certain point if he's not doing him he's
not doing them and that's just somehow
times how roommates are you know when I
think of roommates I think of two people
arguing over dishes that's what I think
of and somebody else ends up writing
their name on the damn spaghetti sauce
and then I mean we had a guy who jumped
out of his own window tried to kill
himself when he was on drugs or so
but he was only in the first floor so he
ended up just breaking his window and
damaging a set of venetian blinds but he
was an idiot you know but he tried to
kill it he tried to you know we had
roommate wars and all that [ __ ] and
people losing their mind you know I mean
things can have with the roommates where
you can be fun you want to be in a fun
environment and I remember one time you
know eating some drugs or something and
been on LSD and cooking a pizza and the
dryer you know and I'll take I'll tell
you this it takes four hours for a
medium for a medium to be edible and
that's one thing I learned by having fun
with my roommates you know we should get
drunk and my roommate would um let me
lay on the hood of his car and he would
drive me all around town you know back
when you could be young and fun not now
not now but I think you need to quit
expecting them you sound like a parent
and I'm going to sound like a parent
calling in so you're going to just get
finally getting a better mind space
here's what I would do I would maybe sit
and let them know how you feel but not
from you can't come from a point of
anger just say this is what's going on
you need to take that stuff where his
his silver spoon kid and all that [ __ ]
out of it that doesn't matter that's his
life and that your lives are different
oh well that's that but I would sit
there and just let him know how you feel
that you you know you just need some
more help with things all from the idea
maybe getting a maid that way you guys
aren't milling around fighting about it
and then dude it's going to sound crazy
bro I pray for the dude pray for him for
two weeks man you're thinking this is
some Christian ideas and I'm not saying
that just two weeks in a row every day
just hope the best for him that's what
you want to do hope the best man I hope
he just sleeps all day and pure comfort
well I handled it the the chores because
then here's what happens is then you
then you suddenly you are a proponent of
his so even if you have these issues you
start to you start he starts to become
something you're cheering for instead of
something you are angry against it
sounds crazy but it'll adjust that
perspective inside of you man and those
are just my thoughts man those are
things that I would do if I were in that
scenario that [ __ ] might not work out
you guys might end up you know taking
scissors to each other's necks you know
and they might be playing this this this
call in a court case soon who knows bro
but um but that's what I'm sharing with
you that's my basic life suggestion for
this
all right let's crack into another one
thank you very much for calling - I do
want to say that I do appreciate the
calls I know this week who'd wanted
people to call in who we're missing an
appendage if somebody had lost an arm or
you know I know a man who cut his wiener
off one time when he was on drugs up
there in Mississippi and his family used
to run the Ramada and he cut off his
wiener up there and he's better now and
he dealt with all that but but I've just
I'm always real curious as to what it's
like if somebody's missing an appendage
and just how that feels and you know is
it a constant thing where you think
about it every day or you just get used
to it I don't I didn't get any calls
about that I don't think so if somebody
has that and they're just afraid to
share I want you to know that I'm not
trying to make fun of you or or if you
have a friend that you might think could
call in and tell us about that that's
what I want to know is we just some
behind the scenes of not having a leg or
you know just some kind of tips tips and
tips and hints if you don't have a leg
or an arm or if you know someone who
doesn't have them give us a buzz all
right let's move on to another call here
we go this is from abroad hey feel so
second-time calm um just watching your
podcast right now I'm just waking up I'm
actually working abroad working on our
Ukraine Ukraine now if you're not
familiar with Ukraine that's over there
near Russia Poland that's a wild it's a
it's a Wild West a lot of snowball
fights a lot of children with stone
shoes and you know girls carrying stone
stone dolls around it's a it's a tough
life over there so thank you for calling
internationally brother onward their
English teacher you're an English
teacher anyway just having a few issues
you know over here by myself alone in
the Ukraine also the Ukraine is a lot of
where those movies hostel and those
movies where a kid get murdered or not
children adults get murdered on their
spring break and stuff so that's I guess
a popular pastime in Ukraine onward
working abroad over here I got a girl
that I'm dealing with seeing her for a
few months and it's just these girls
these days man they just they don't even
officially say here here's Armand talks
she's already expecting me to go to like
family birthday isn't just stuff I'm not
into the crazy part is my second time
already dealing with Ukrainian girls
right okay so he's having some issues
here with these Ukrainian girls you know
they're expecting a lot out of him and
he's not having the talks they're not
you know things aren't becoming clear
you know if you if it's if it's a
serious relationship or just a dating or
something like that I'm guessing let's
listen more you meet then you start
hanging with them everything is cool you
tell me want to take it slow you look
serious and then all of a sudden you're
just like buying birthday presents and I
don't know man what do you think about
that on these girls just soon as they
get what you did sack like your
girlfriend you'll have no discussions
have a good one man once again
long-distance phone call it's costing me
money all right well I appreciate you
making that investment in this past
weekend the Ukrainian girls man if you
call them I mean for let's be honest man
if you have it every two Ukrainians a
lot of them you know they do it they got
a lot of play up tell you how big outfit
up to shoot here a lot of that
pornography comes out of the Ukraine and
you know the Soviet Union and you know
those girls like to be they like to get
wild in a real but universe over there
but here's the thing you said you're
taking it slow you tell these girls were
taking it slow but even if taking this
slow for a few months that builds up
speed man you know in the mind of a
woman you know they they things start to
mean something to them you know if you
spend time you know I got to gather them
and it's just starting to spend some
time with and that makes me I get
nervous you know I get nervous because
for me it's just am I ready to be a man
do I think I can be that you know that's
stable can I be a stable man in a
relationship am i there enough yet in my
head and in my heart do I have enough of
my things taking care of in my life to
do to do that to really be that man but
for you it sounds like you just want to
be casual but these women start
expecting something and then you're
going to birthdays and parties and
fiestas and you know y'all are you know
you guys might be doing you know you
think you're just taking a walk but then
she have y'all jump into a carriage ride
and now y'all are carriage riders or
listening to somebody play the violin or
whatever they do over there rush to
listen to somebody you know softly beat
their children you know under a by
candlelight or whatever romance happens
over there you know just watching
somebody wash their forehead with soapy
water or whatever you know I'm polish so
I know you know I'm polish Nicaraguan so
I know some of you know I got in my
blood some of what's going on over there
I can hear it in my heartbeat sometimes
some of the the the trite magic that
comes out of there of from that from the
Far Eastern Europe but I'll say this man
I think you you don't want anything
tears but these girls going to start to
expect it and one of the craziest types
of women to date are Russian women or
Eastern European women you know that bro
you know that you have to know that I
mean they will they will I've dated one
girl in LA that was a Russian girl and
then she actually went to jail for
beating up her landlord
I think I'm pretty sure like
eighty-eight percent sure seven or 75 or
something percent sure I know she was on
trial for it because she tried to get me
to come down the courthouse a few times
beautiful girl you know and she just
they all want to be Lara Croft Tomb
Raider you know and I don't know what
happened but they get wild and that's
why I say you know it's tough to date
some of those ladies because they they
will knuckle into you you know they just
have that Cold War in them they got the
dark arts they grew up playing with
stone dolls and eating wooden candy and
when you grow up with that rough of a
childhood when you finally get a little
something you get them you get anything
even if it's somebody's feelings you
know feelings are a big or a commodity
there when you're when you live in a
land that has nothing when you live in a
land that second and third world
I remember the Olympics some of the they
said that some of the hurdles were made
out of goat bones and stuff I mean they
didn't these people were putting [ __ ]
together you know I remember um you know
some of the places were people Olympians
were sleeping were just other people's
houses they just sent them to like a
rich person's house and hope that the
rich person would let them stay like
that's crazy it's not crazy me says it's
not crazy it's one of the things that
comes with a third world nation man so
if you're over there and people don't
have anything to eat you know if you
take a woman out on a date and the best
y'all can even get is maybe a you know a
bowl of fish soup or something to share
and y'all are sharing just some salmon
soup and you know then the feelings that
you give or the emotions that you give
her those are going to be a bigger a big
commodity you know where you get it over
in the first world you get over in LA or
Birmingham Alabama or some of these
fancy spots and these women don't give a
[ __ ] about the feelings you know and not
all of them but when you get into these
higher money areas that's when they care
about the Lamborghinis you know in the
vichy dresses and the
you know the vault of Ivaldi designer
bags and all this [ __ ] so you're over
there we're a hot commodity is feelings
in time and I'm actually I'm envious of
you man because it sounds a given la
mindset but you have it over there in a
place where where people want to be
attached and you know we're living here
in America where we want I think a lot
of people want a little bit more
attachment so if you don't care about it
maybe you know then let her go if she's
getting too attached you know think
about it like this say you are allowed
to fish somewhere and they say yeah you
can catch the fish and you can enjoy
them you know you can hug them by the
bank and touch them if you want you know
you can be wild with them and you have
fun you tell the fish right when you
catch it you know I'm just going to keep
you here by the bank with me and it's
just going to be fun then you throw the
fish back in the water what do you think
that fish is honestly going to do you've
been over there snuggling with that fish
and licking its side and touching its
gills and y'all been getting to know
each other for weeks this is a fish
that's been living underwater and here
it is breathing air breathing air next
to another another being a human but
still another being you think that fish
is going to swim off not care no it's
not gonna especially a third-world fish
man we're we're affection and time are
commodities so you add that those things
into the fact that Eastern European
women are 70 or 58 or 65% psychopath or
pretty edgy mentally edgy dude that's
fire right there you're flirtin with
fire so if you over there getting your
dick burnt I'm not surprised but what
advice do I have for you at a certain
point you got to commit otherwise just
quit just at a certain point you
probably have to commit or you need to
be more Stern and we're getting and let
them know what the scenario is
but don't get angry at them and if they
invite you to a birthday party get a
damn present
dude you know go out there you might
meet somebody at a birthday party that's
a special event they got cake and they
might have camel you know we're not Toni
rides or whatever you guys have over
there Moscow mules you know you could
probably do anything who knows what you
they're even eating over there a
birthday somebody probably only lives to
about 11 or 12 and Ukraine go over there
and celebrate 15 percent of their life
they're inviting you go enjoy that be a
part of something so I appreciate you
call a man and I feel you you know if
you don't want to be involved but be
feel feel feel feel sorry feel thankful
because they got men over here looking
for some action looking for love and
these women are offering it to you so at
least treat the women with some
gratitude you know enough that they care
but good luck man good luck to you and I
appreciate you calling under
international alright let's get another
one right here let's see where we're at
time was about 40 minutes thank you guys
for paying a pay attention and being
involved I'm also considering this
patreon where we do some maybe we do
special episodes each week or something
like that but I'm considering patreon or
patreon I'm in this motel and I just
heard my neighbor I think they're pissed
off I don't blame them I mean I'm the
dude he's chatting about you know
Ukrainian you know dating habits through
the walls at 3:19 in the morning all
right here's another this was a text
that came in deal what's up man this is
Andrew from Iowa huge fan of all your
stuff I look forward to your podcast
every week so I have the situation I
want to talk to you about I've been
seeing this girl
we have hooked up four times every time
we end up going for it for about an hour
Wow you having sex for an hour dude well
that's your problem right there if you
give a woman an hour of sex they're
going to want more sex dude my move give
a woman seven or eight minutes of
troublesome awkward sex and then they
might not want it
so I want to consider that just to kind
of slow down the pace you're on this is
only the second girl I've had relations
with and the same thing happened the two
times I hooked up with the first girl so
I know the answer to this is to stop
jerking it but I wanted to ask you how
you get to sleep when you're abstaining
from masturbation I've gotten into the
routine of jerking it and falling asleep
real fast I'm sober now so booze is not
an option I really want to quit the
masturbation so I can have better sex
thanks dude
Andra I appreciate you reaching out from
Iowa I've had some good times in Iowa I
visited the field of dreams there the
actual one from the movie site from the
movie filming it's there and it's a nice
thing to see if you drive through Iowa I
also I also had a good chicken-fried
steak there but let me answer your
question you can't finish sexually so if
you essentially you aren't finishing so
what bro huh
so what dude I have sex sometimes and
don't finish you know you're not wrong
for that you don't have to finish every
time have you ever started playing
basketball and then it rains guess what
dude you didn't finish bro now if you're
jerking off right before bed and that's
your issue um then the problem is you
you you have all that energy you need to
get rid of that energy throughout the
day you know and you got to get you have
to get out and play hoops or you know
get some kettlebells or kick a ball
around the yard do soccer with the
neighbor you know or find some way to
get that energy out of it go to the gym
you know if it's mental energy and you
and that's what's causing you to jerk
out and to skied up then you need to why
you know what I do sometimes I'll watch
car accidents on the internet you know
that will sometimes help me tone down
I'll burn something in the bathroom sink
you know burn an old shoe or some piece
of paper you know something to get to
might get that edge off of me you know
something will let the devil out because
what's happening to you is
if you're not if you're feeling like you
have to ejaculate to get that devil out
of you that's not true you can get that
devil out of you by some other way you
can chop the tree down you could dig a
hole in the yard put something in there
you know do a time capsule you could
just go for a run you could lift weights
but you can watch karate watch old adult
karate on the internet they got senior
citizen karate you know it kind of it's
exciting but it's not too violent where
it makes me scared to go to bed but it
helps take some of that nervous energy
out of me watching that attack
you know those attack moves so anyhow I
hope that answers your question
but don't feel bad if you're not
spraying out during sex man you don't
have to okay that's something you see in
pornography you don't have to spray out
but I commend you on being sober and and
if you think it sounds like you're
answering your question for you for you
you know you're answering your own
question you know you said so I know the
answer to this is to stop jerking it and
that's probably is the overall answer is
to take away take that time away you
know you'll be more involved and you'll
actually get the release from where it's
supposed to come from you know another
human but if it's in if it's anxiety if
it's that that devil in you if it's that
mental nut that you know that that you
feel that devil just gearing up and
you're hardening your rectum it in your
crotch then you need to find a way to
let that out and that I think is is
doing the gym or doing watching car
accidents online or doing watch an adult
karate or you know doing ping pong I
don't do yo-yos or any of that kind of
[ __ ] that shit's boring I think a yo-yo
but anyhow good luck to you man the best
of best of love and luck to you out
there as you backing off that's that
skeet and focusing on heaven naturally
Jack's at the end of sex but don't feel
bad if you don't and I appreciate you
call them and I appreciate you sharing
on
this uh not calling but sharing this uh
text with us all right man let's check
in one more here we go and this one um
this is what I want to bet I want to
leave us on here man this guy he had
some thoughts dude I really liked them
and uh and I want to end us on this here
let me see if I can find this here we go
right here let's go
he'll see Oh what up my name is Ben a
white dude from the suburbs of New York
City white dude from the suburbs of New
York you hear that
we got an Uzi on the line ladies and
gentlemen thank you for calling Ben this
is response to your future predictions
in bids : about the future he called it
about two weeks ago I think and we're
talking about the future and things like
that and I want to get back into some of
that and I'm going to use this call to
lead us there I'm gonna want to I want
to know what you guys think about what
Ben says here here we go I think what's
come in ten years from now there's going
to be a big cultural meltdown I feel
between what it means to be a man and a
woman from my generation
okay so been saying what it means to be
a man a woman from his generation
cultural meltdown here we go because
right now there's a whole bunch of
blurred lines and all that and it's
getting just in great he right now a lot
of blurred lines right now I agree or at
least yeah I agree but the fact is I saw
that yesterday on snapchat saying you
know three million women are graduating
from college every year and then the
result of that is going to be you know
major income inequality coming up and
when it comes time to raise a family and
stuff you know my generation is pretty
lost in terms of what it means to be in
that wouldn't need to be able to so he's
saying that he's saying that there will
be three million more women a year
graduating college than men into a into
a generation where already there's a
very blurred line of what it means to be
a man and what it means to be a woman
this is interesting and I looked that up
and and he's right according to
different studies there appears to be
more women graduating college and
enrolling in college than men onward the
roles that we have to play and I just
don't think that we're ready for that
going from being completely lost of what
it means to be no man woman to being
thrown into the hard position of being
the reliance house let's back it up for
one second so we get all the what he
said I shouldn't have interrupted that
here we go just family and stuff you
know my generation is pretty lost in
terms of what it means to be a man
wouldn't need to be within the rules
that we have to play and I just don't
think they were ready for that going
from being completely lost of what it
means to be you know men women to being
thrown into the hard position of being
the reliant spouse in a marriage and I
think that's going to cause major
cultural turmoil and you know who knows
what the result of that is going to be
so yeah ten years from now I think
that's going to add wow you hear that
he's saying in ten years within ten
years the effects that are going to be
really wild when women when more women
are the the reliant bread earners in
families and in relationships and in
marriages than men and just overall you
know I mean that's scary to me I mean it
is scary I don't think it's scary
because women will be the ones making
more money it's scary because I worry
about what effect that might have on a
man on the psyche of a man are we moving
too fast for our psyches to be able to
handle it
you know I mean there's something
intrinsic and a man where you want to be
the provider where you want to be you
know the one who's bringing home the
Duckett's you know stacks on stacks you
know and now it's going to be women it's
going to be women who are
doing this in ten years that's what he
theorizes so I'd like to know what some
of you guys have thoughts on do you
agree on this I'm going to put it out an
episode on Thursday evening it's just
about this like what do you think what
do you think about what he has to say
here you know do you think this is true
do you think gets wild do you worry
about that I mean in ten years I mean I
grew up with a single with just a single
mother so it's like you know I was used
to our mother being the breadwinner but
would it have been different if my had
same age parents are similar and then
that mom is making all the money and the
dad is dealing with the feelings of that
or is that just going to be commonplace
where you know the the fact that men
feel like they need to be that is going
to start to disappear that that's just
an old an old feeling that you know that
we don't need to have anymore
almost like the appendix you know for we
you know this theory that at some point
the appendix was necessary for man but
that now it's just this piece in your
body that gets infected sometimes when
you're playing Little League baseball
and you have to go to the hospital
immediately so what's it going to be man
you know because that could be startling
and are these women want to be you know
are they're just going to be the
breadwinners and then still want to be
mothers are they going to be you know
insane aggressive feminists you know one
thing I notice about a lot of aggressive
feminists they're not mothers they don't
have any children you know you look at a
lot of these leave these you know like
these extreme pro-hillary feminists
during the election stuff a lot of them
go with a celebrity one that I see not
mothers don't have any biological
children of their own does that play a
role you know does that is that where
we're headed where women don't want to
be carrying babies anymore
they just want to you know be
breadwinners I don't know and what what
will men feel like what are we gonna
feel like you know when you come home
your wife you know got all the cash and
she's you got to ask her for money
man might just be like this is
getting awesome you know maybe it's time
for us to take you know that's that side
seat and let women do it are we still
going to feel sexually attracted to
those women you know will the are we
headed towards a gender war 200 years
from now can Wonder Woman defeat Al
Bundy from married with children a lot
of questions out there but I love that I
love that final question there and that
was by Fiona that was Ben that's from
Mount Kisco area and that's New York
outside of the city and I love that I
love that he called and I appreciate
that it's a great question man it's a
great question we're going to leave it
there and that's something you guys can
call any comment on this week and I'm
trying to put up a special about that on
Thursday that's going to be the goal and
also we're considering patreon or
patreon where we do something special
for listeners each month it's kind of a
subscription-based service I just want
to know what you think about this it's
something I'm considering just so that I
can get into like a regular type of
studio space maybe get us a little bit
better camera and just have some you
know a producer that's helping
constantly I'm fortunate enough right
now I got this guy sure who brings us
into his studios over on in conscious
studios I got a guy Adam who helps give
me advice I got a guy Chris and my buddy
Ken Hyland and Chris Mach oh you know I
got guys helping out but I'd love to be
able to you know things cost money I
love to be able to create a system
that's a little bit stronger but also I
don't want to damage what we have going
on
I'm great for you you guys for calling
in you can also feel feel free to call
in and hit the hotline with any other
issues or problems whatever's going on
man you got something your brain
something in your heart drop it in there
you know and I appreciate it man if I
can relate at all I will share my
experience or if you hit me with a
stumper and you hit you got my brain
going then I'm going to share like we
did here just now with Nick you know
because that's that's wild to think that
in ten years women could have all that
money you know and is that just change
the dynamic of what it means to be in a
relationship
and what it means how that fence is it
can we still be a man if we're not the
breadwinner can you still feel like a
man I mean it's hard to feel like one
now you know I don't start to feel like
one but it's hard to feel like you can
express that you're one but also think
some of that's just America you know I
hope it is and hopefully it's just a
phase that we're going through and some
of this evens out because I think we
should all be able to have the true joy
of of whatever our gender is you know or
even if you're gender-neutral you should
be able to have that joy whatever that
is you know I don't think somebody has
to win and that's what I don't like
about some of the feminism it's like
they have to win why do you have to win
you don't have to you're not beating men
okay equality means that we're all
trying to figure it out and working
together and some things I don't want to
be equal you know because some things
aren't for debate some things aren't
they're not something you can equate you
know I still want women to be women and
men to be men because I think that's a
beautiful little puzzle that that we've
been trying to put together for for
centuries and I don't want us to stop
that you know and I think that's nature
that's about nature works that's how
nature works man
so and I love that man I'm a Romeo and
Juliet er you know that but I think you
guys for calling in this week madam will
leave us out here I'll see you guys next
weekend at Colusa Casino and then I will
see you coming up soon Nashville's you
have any friends in Nashville July 7th
and 8th send them out man
I'm excited for that weekend it's going
to be a lot of fun all right here we go
man on the way out thank you guys for
hanging out on this past weekend
[Music]
called drift apart an epidemic sounds
Oh
[Music]
are we drifting apart man as men and
women I don't know I didn't see it as
much in you know you get out of Los
Angeles and get into like Pittsburgh
though you see a lot of women wanting to
be women
men what will be men so that's nice to
see it's also nice to know there's a lot
of empowered women out Andrew Steele you
know that it's a more of a team effort
sometimes and men who recognize that
that's important called drift apart man
and we drifted apart in this world for
but I still believe that his ways not
fit and I still believe at the core that
people are good people there's got to
spend time with them in real time we got
to figure it out we keep showing up we
move all morning we'll get it done man
we'll get there I hope we'll get to a
good place
all right look there what you guys think
man hit me up on the hotline have a
great week take care of yourself as you
probably deserve okay
be good to yourself is our best that you
deserve yell of a girl
[Music]